de plus en plus on observe d orage et
des éclairs bien au-delà du cercle
arctique où il était jusque là très rare
aujourd'hui il représente un nouveau
risque pour le déclenchement d'un
incendie dans l'arctique
imaginez des éclairs vue de là haut au
spectacle réservé aux astronautes à bord
de la station spatiale internationale
se taire de nombre des clercs annuel
atteint 2,2 à 2,5 milliards
les trois quarts des éclairs surviennent
entre les nuages
le quart seulement à telle somme au
canada par exemple en 2021 on a compté
près de 18 millions des clercs séance
pas moins qu aux etats unis ce qui a
permis de savoir c'est un système
mondial de détection des éclairs le
globo est une étoile
la compagnie vaisala
c'est un réseau de récepteurs terrestre
qui capte les signaux électromagnétiques
produits par les éclairs du cese les
ondes produites par les éclairs se
disperse autour de la terre à la vitesse
de la lumière
nos capteurs placés à des endroits
stratégiques autour du globe traite
spécifiquement ces signaux
mais s'il ya un endroit où les éclairs
sont rares
c'est un article enfin cetera
comme la température et grimpe de 3 à 4
fois plus vite qu'ailleurs que la glace
disparaît que l'eau se réchauffe et
s'évapore l'air se charge d'humidité et
les conditions deviennent propices à la
formation d'orages
en 2021 on a détecté cette huile est
clair au total
c'était presque deux fois le nombre
combiné des clercs détecter les neuf
années précédentes c'est un nombre
significatif à ces latitudes et même au
delà de 80 degrés nord
à l'été 2010 9 des éclairs sont détectés
à 50 kilomètres seulement du pôle nord
une latitude à laquelle la foudre n'a
jamais été détectée
en alaska dès orange plus violente qu'à
l'habitude ont été observés par les
météorologues durant les derniers étés
il y a eu quelques événements météo
sévère en alaska on a eu des vents
violents qui sévissent est pendant des
orages
on a même eu l'été dernier une attente
précipitations grêle
mettant titre comparé la fréquence des
éclairs au delà du cercle arctique sur
une plus longue période reste hasardeuse
pour certains c'est que les systèmes de
détection des claires à ces latitudes
sont très récents
la capacité de détection et d'après moi
ce qui explique surtout pourquoi on n'en
voit plus
à l'été 2000 21 par exemple trois
oranges successifs en provenance de la
sibérie frappent le nord de l'alaska
avec une série d' éclairs
c'est d'ailleurs un éclair qui a
déclenché un feu au nord ouest de
l'alaska l'été 2021 le même été en
sibérie le feu s'est étendu sur plus de
800 mille hectares des chercheurs de
l'université libre d'amsterdam
on étudie les sites de ces feux en
sibérie
la majorité des feux sont allumés par
des humains dans les régions reculées de
l'arctique la bougie d'allumage ce sont
les éclairs presque tous les feux à
l'intérieur du cercle arctique sans
déclencher par des éclairs
[Musique]
bien sûr ce ne sont pas tous les éclairs
qui peuvent déclencher des feux mais
comme la forêt et la toundra s'assèche
avec la hausse des températures la
capacité d'initier augmente
ce serait donc la combinaison des
matières sèches au sol et des nombreux
éclairs qui causeraient les allumages et
les feux dans l'extrême nord
avec l'intensification des feux en était
à de très hautes latitudes
on a aussi observé un curieux phénomène
l'hiver qui suit
des feux qui courent incognito dans les
profondeurs de la tour bien on les
appelle zambie files il se consume
lentement tout l'hiver sous la neige
[Musique]
les feux déclenchés par les éclairs
surviennent surtout au solstice d'été en
juin
mais avec ses fantômes qui perdure tout
l'hiver les sites seront flammes
aussitôt qu'un âge a disparu résultat la
saison des feux commence plus tôt
à l'été 2010 9 en sibérie le feu laisse
une grande cicatrice sur ce territoire
durant tout l'hiver tout semble éteint
mais le feu court sous la neige très tôt
au printemps le feu redémarre sur le
pourtour du 7 incendies l'été précédent
et gagne du terrain tout l'été suivant
cette tourbière certain super isolant si
vous avez un feu qui consume des couches
profondes de cette tourbière il va être
isolés de la neige et du froid tout au
dessus de ses propriétés isolantes
contribuer à maintenir l'activité de ce
feu
avec la récurrence et l'intensification
de ses feux au delà du cercle polaire
vient aussi la probabilité que des
nuages de fumée produisent leur propre
est clair on l'a vu en colombie
britannique
durant les feux de 2021 les épais nuage
de fumée créé au micro système qui
génère ses propres est clair ils
s'ajoutent aux éclairs des systèmes
orageux à proximité
enjoy
en 15 heures sont à détecter 700000
éclair à travers la colombie britannique
à la fois entre les nuages et des nuages
vers le sol ces éclairs ont pu
déclencher d'autres feu à leur tour
à l'été 2000 22 des équipes canadiennes
et hollandaises ont arpenté des zones
récemment dévastés par les feux dans les
territoires du nord-ouest
ils souhaitent mieux comprendre l'effet
combiné de ces feux sur des émissions de
carbone
si les feux atteignent de grandes
profondeurs alors vous risquez de
consommer ce carbone anciens que vous
allez relâché dans l'atmosphère
la chaleur les éclaire les feux les
émissions supplémentaires de dioxyde de
carbone un cercle vicieux auquel même
l'arctique ne pourra échapper
[Musique]